[Musique]
on l'entend souvent les applications
récoltent énormément de données à notre
sujet mais saviez-vous qu'il est
possible de limiter les permissions
qu'on leur accorde
[Musique]
sur iPhone c'est assez simple il suffit
d'ouvrir l'application réglage
et une fois qu'on est là défilé et
choisir l'application de notre choix
dans mon cas ce sera Tic-Toc
et une fois qu'on est là on peut changer
les autorisations qu'on accorde à
l'application donc par exemple je peux
désactiver
l'accès à ma géolocalisation au
microphone à mon appareil photo c'est
aussi simple que ça sur Android il y a
quelques étapes supplémentaires mais ça
reste assez simple il suffit d'ouvrir
l'application paramètres de descendre et
choisir l'option application
encore une fois choisir l'application de
notre choix dans ce cas si ce sera
Facebook
choisir encore autorisation et là on
peut choisir lorsque si je désactiverais
la géolocalisation il y a aussi un autre
moyen de limiter les données que vont
récolter des applications sur notre
téléphone essayer de désactiver notre
identifiant publicitaire ça c'est ce qui
permet aux publicitaires essentiellement
de pister nos activités sur des
applications et sur des sites web pour
se faire sur iPhone on ouvrira encore
l'application réglages
on choisit l'option confidentialité et
sécurité
ensuite l'onglet suivi et on peut tout
simplement désactiver pour toutes les
applications
encore une fois sur Android c'est un peu
plus compliqué on part de l'application
paramètres
on choisit ensuite sécurité et
confidentialité on choisit ensuite
l'option confidentialité
autre paramètres de confidentialité
annonce et là on peut supprimer
l'identifiant publicitaire ça se peut
que ça varie un peu d'un appareil à
l'autre du Android mais en gros c'est ça
les étapes à suivre gardez en tête que
même ces mesures-là vont protéger un peu
votre vie privée c'est pas une solution
magique ces applications là vous disent
de plusieurs autres manières la seule
manière vraiment de faire en sorte qu'on
ne puisse pas du tout c'est pas utiliser
cette application là et n'oubliez pas de
bien faire vos recherches